[Musique]
oui
oh
[Musique]
ma mère
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on avait l'ambiance du carnaval la
chronique sur la culture guyanaise
pendant la période du carnaval on l'a
transposé sur le bateau avec tous les
ingrédients les ingrédients y étaient
m
[Musique]
c'est le but justement c'est d'abord nos
compatriotes martiniquais guadeloupéens
venir ce bateau et s'associe aux
guyanais pour découvrir cette culture
parce que bon gars d hilary hahn et
martinique et guadeloupe et calais est
quand même mais n'oublions pas que
chaque année durant la ligne droite nous
avons des charters de martiniquais
guadeloupéens qui arrive en guyane pour
le carnaval c'était pour ceux qui ne
connaissaient pas on a invité sur 60 ans
ce sont surtout ceux qui ne
connaissaient pas cette tradition pour
les inviter à venir nous revenons de
bateaux et tous ceux qui sont venus et b
sont agréablement surpris alors rome ne
s'est pas fait en un jour
soyons clairs c'est pas tout le monde
qui adhèrent aux costumes parce que
c'est pas évident avant un costume sur
soi toute la soirée
donc ça te sont venus son costume ils
ont adoré leur dis pourquoi pas les
prochaines revenir avec leurs costumes
non
[Musique]
je
bon
[Musique]
m
pas
[Musique]
damphousse et